[Music]
the underdog never has it easy arson is
only really broken into the scene I
would say over the past six months the
odds are always stacked against them
often from birth forgetting the visa our
different countries the populace very
difficult there are dozens hundreds of
obstacles standing between them and
greatness the visa was declined the
first time he was kind of discouraged he
actually messaged me he was saying Hasan
I don't know if I want to do this
anymore maybe I should just give up but
in the end when it really matters the
underdog will find a way
our three-round come back let's go if he
beats everyone that be packs there at
the best country in the world a ticket
the fighting game world has always
revolved around two or three major
regions every great fighting game has
incredible players from either North
America or Japan Korea also stands out
particularly in Tekken where they
dominate the same what's a legend he is
back takes that trophy and he's gonna be
taking it home to South Korea of course
Europe South America China and the
Middle East have all produced standout
players across dozens of games but
Pakistan has never really been in the
conversation despite having the sixth
highest population in the world with
over 200 million people Pakistani
citizens often have trouble acquiring
visas to get to Japan Korea or the
United States where most tech and
tournaments are held but if you do not
have money you have to struggle for the
visa for getting the visa or different
countries the populist body that
historically this meant that the
Pakistani second tyranny didn't travel
it also meant that most people didn't
know they existed so they didn't go to
Pakistan to train with them there were a
few people outside of Pakistan who knew
about the country's incredible secret
Tekken seen them in 2010 a Pakistani
player named awesome arrived in the UK
and proceeded to mop the floor with the
British that can see literally in Tekken
6 when he came down he was unbeatable
like he beats everyone you know in order
for someone to be as good as he he is
and he was it means that you're seen in
yours yeah you're seeing your local
scene must be really good as well and
then he told them about our fun ash
legal system trust me if this guy
arsalan comes down to - anywhere he'll
be all the Koreans and I believe them I
believe that you've only told me this
years ago but but no one else did people
often people actually laughed at us and
when he said this
I think the Tekken is the most popular
game in Pakistan because it is played
around everywhere in Pakistan in every
city and I would be split with the
Pakistani scene see they've been playing
Tekken for a very long time so you know
I've been hearing stories about how
they've been playing a very very high
level since Tekken 5 and they developed
their own style
Oracle finally got the chance to travel
in 2018 when he went to the South East
Asia major for his first international
Tekken tournament before the tournament
he was playing a lot of fests attends
and junuh who's a very well-known
commentator he said there's just random
Pakistani dude killing all the Koreans
and Japanese guys infest attends like
he's budding everyone I don't know who
he is but he's he's being everyone and
that to me was that okay that's our
still on
he plays nice but well most of the
Korean and Japanese players who showed
up but a respectable performance
nonetheless and one he'd quickly outdo
arson went to Dubai a few months later
for the oug tournament which quickly
turned into his coming out party
Sofi / Ocelot from Pakistan vs. rocks
dragony from Korea then I know the next
match is with me I went outside of the
place and I just thinking that I will
definitely gonna put me all at first and
I definitely gonna put my all struggle
for these years into this match and I
was not thinking about the winning and
losing I was just thinking of beating
him I was thinking of giving him a - I'm
a suspect so dirty right now yeah doing
his best work
so far superfast and that's it Wow the
PD gets beat by us in speed by Arsenal
3-0 o ug tournament congratulations to
also for Pakistan but many people were
ready to call his wins over knee a fluke
they didn't see a unique style of Tekken
being played at a high level they saw a
no-name from the middle of nowhere
beating one of the best Tekken players
in the world and somehow they didn't
immediately put some respect on Arsenal
Nash's name I mean of course you've got
people who were saying he was playing
off his game that but when you actually
analyze the games which is what I did I
made a video on YouTube analyzing how he
beat me it's quite clear to see that it
was it was a Salaam and really well he
just looked unstoppable there he didn't
lose a single game to me and you know be
everyone else Chris he's pretty easily
as well in order to get the respect that
Horace on and Pakistan deserve in order
to get the wins he knew he could Arslan
actually need to travel again this time
to the biggest tournament he could
possibly attend evo japan evo japan is
not as big as its american sibling but
it's still a prestigious tournament see
even Japan doesn't bring out the same
kind of numbers that Evo and Las Vegas
does every year but the caliber of
players is incredibly high by the way I
need to know I need to remind y'all this
is losing someone put coot on - losers
well before topic even Japan attracts
the top players who can travel sure but
the main Evo in Vegas does that - the
main difference between evo Japan and
every Western tournament he's a massive
contingent of players from the eastern
hemisphere who can't necessarily afford
to go to Evo in Vegas every summer these
are amazing players players who get to
go to arcades and play with the top
players in Asia regularly and the
Western players don't even know their
names you cannot prepare for them like I
said man these are matches that you will
not see outside of Evo Japan man so
y'all need to get ready man there's a
lot of legacy and matchups like this
combined with the legion of top players
you already know about our Celyn ass was
walking into the Lions Den but getting
to Japan was its own problem his visa
was delayed because of issues with the
paperwork he was kind of discouraged he
actually messaged me he was saying
Hassan I don't know if I want to do this
anymore maybe I should just give up and
I said no don't give up
we'll get your invitation that's and
it's going to be accepted don't worry
about it and he was like okay so he kept
his determination managed to get the
visa getting his hands on a visa was
just the first step though after he had
won he can book his plane tickets you
can go straight from Pakistan to Japan
you know allowed to take a direct flight
for some reason there's some legal
reasons why he Khan he was supposed to
go from Pakistan to Thailand to Fukuoka
getting to Japan just a few days early
but when he got to the airport he wasn't
allowed to get on the plane then
tomorrow again my possible nearly 20
cuts from here to Malaysia from Malaysia
to Korea from Korea to KUKA and when I
was in Malaysia after maybe six hours
I'd slide is from Malaysia to Korea I go
to the counter and I gave him my
passport and tickets and he said you
can't go to a Korean because we don't
have any visa the second is my sponsor
book me a flight to Tokyo
not from Fukuoka when I was about to
board my flight they store pain they are
saying that in your password the
immigration officer stamped that you are
going to Korea and then to Fukuoka why
do you change your flight why did you
change your flight I I was I told him
the whole story
then somehow I managed to beg them I
begged them and I luckily very humble
people they allowed me to go
unfortunately
the complications didn't stop the Tokyo
Airport currency exchange didn't take
Pakistani rupees I stay here for one
month they eat without eating anything I
said to my sponsor that I am leaving
boom this book me a ticket from here to
the hole because there were only four
hours left for the tournament
thankfully again the V / guys came
through they they booked a flight for
him from Tokyo - to Fukuoka and then
paid for his taxi and by the time he all
that goes like three days of passed at
this point
manages to get to the venue
evo japan literally when his pool starts
our flesh showed up to pools after three
days straight of start and stop travel
after not eating or sleeping properly
and he already had more to prove than
anybody else in that room so he was out
for blood
I was something nor no more than Islam
at that time I was something else Arslan
was such an unknown that his early
matches weren't even streamed but that
didn't stop him from bringing down me
once again I already know
after three matches I have to piss me I
always prepared for Nia game I was not
thinking about writing better than a
valid
JDC our champion I just want to dream I
just want to win because I suffered a
lot I was not thinking there are easily
I just want to give my best
most people Deven you've heard that knee
went down but they didn't know who did
it
some random Pakistani player they didn't
know his story but they were about to
learn his name I was constantly like
like scared for him right I was like oh
man he's got pay this dude now man I
wonder what's gonna happen and then they
just you just can't win him Arsenal took
a loss to bowl of B but went on to
defeat Chanel and rixton two huge names
in Korean and na tagging respectively
ours LOD beat Rick stuff
he also eliminated Chanel before that
game all of them - OH
the same man who sent me to loser
bracket is still in the tournament
that's around the time the stream staff
took notice and put him on camera for a
match against a low high the defending
Evo champion against the underdog a
tournament favorite against a guy who
didn't even get a full night's sleep you
guys asked her to come to the stream
here we go yeah buying low high I would
be terrified right now this guy's taking
all the Korean players he knows that
beat the Korean play style so ready
prove it oh my god that was it that was
God like his round but oh my god to mix
up too complicated so confident first
game to our thought although the ad
Beauchamp
well like trying to stay alive
tournament life on the line here watch
this one one two with the whip planted
on the throw arsalan eliminates low high
the 2018
Evo champion out of the tournament this
like the third Korean he's eliminated
this dude is ridicu to Kout me Chanel
and lo hi next came book the best player
in Thailand and I would say you know his
rhythm as was it's very different what
they happen to be players waving it out
the parry here's the cop you start over
the perfect
yes be in man this is so great - yes
that's a hard time you can make easy but
you can write it tonight and visa the
first time oh yeah I'm happy now look at
his journey or the law the biggest of
big Hopkins punished in trouble last
chance before candy make something
happen
it's all over three rounds rating game -
Arzo that eliminating book book an ace
is seventh place here at evil Japan
world that means we're gonna see Arslan
tag vs. Jimmy J translator our saloons
first real challenge came in his next
match against Jimmy J Tran it's a great
American home USA vs. Pakistan this is
absolutely insane one round away from a
limiting arson - who is up until this
point looked unstoppable in our top
eight cars know what he guy we haven't
seen him in this situation before
how does he fight back with facing
adversity oh and a big counter in - or
again that is the second time in the
last two referees landed in a clutch
situation
be by be late oh you're back beautiful
down for one final round gave you a
given to delayed off you let go tiger
and more than half of his life rode the
running technically maybe trying to move
again oh it Timmy fighting back down
don't count Jimmy out he's got the
random the Blues up tonight and Arthur
with the three rounds come back let's go
it's crazy game of mean you think about
hooking up oh my god he can't believe
he's doing it this is sick he gets to
here running to the follow up here
I don't throw Chad was ready the Bartek
sadboy bar the gym without like 20
seconds you know five minutes ago arts
and ash was on the cusp of getting
eliminated from the tournament back
gosh where's the limit
Jimmy pronto we got the wallet will kind
of come over easy at the ball I'm gonna
break wait oh my god Jimmy J Jed final
final round Jimmy J burdens Ivan let's
get it whoa but no he's chipping away
Jimmy - wait give me the big trouble
oh and the win he's not over though he
got our sling over Jimmy J train what
animate said between players oh my god
that was crazy
that was crazy I underestimate him a bit
but he played outstanding I'd ever run a
moment I told I will lose from him but I
don't know how I managed to him from him
and after that match I was like me tree
shaking
also after that match I was become more
strong
next up was chicory one of Japan's best
players now puts himself up against
Chikara in from Japan not just Japan the
entire crowd here from Fukuoka
we still got max Bullough gonna make
some baby dog get out of here you can't
make some something that you get low
paid for ie
arson - taking that first round drawing
first blood here against ticketed hope I
got off the wall he's banging on video
he's playing horse was up he's got the
park back doesn't but then once
damn who knows you see that beat at wit
pundit your arse Annette this up
goes for the bids oh what a sight step
Wow off-the-wall pick up two very nice
combo conversion this I'm going
downstairs itself Oh Big Mac for is he
gonna make this comment gets it it is
set point for Arthur - last chance for
chicken again
he's down to red can he do the whip you
gotta be careful eliminates Japan from
the tournament and then came cherry
berry mango who took our Celyn as far as
Jimmy J trended if not further to a full
five games what universe are we in right
now this is bizarro world this is insane
this is a new age of Tekken whoo New Age
of Heroes nobody counted for it's not
like this in the wall don't follow go
get the hub over Oh buzzy buzzy doctor
told you what these idiots kill the wall
crap oh you up the low that helps him of
course you do it analyses look at the
whip when beautify dude is coming tying
around his face you can't do woman's man
is facing his children and his Punishers
his wood Punishers at the specific
weight he'd know they reach and cherry
p.m. yeah
cherry very big he's old now but cherry
berry oh we didn't finish it oh it's
going right now he'll sweep I told you
to stop I'd warned
I try to warn you well there's the lodge
doesn't think that move you gotta live
in I mind right the moment of truth here
his cherry berry bag we're gonna have
what it takes to meet you stuff no
inside the perfect career out of the
German Arvin Acrobat that is going to
the grand final finally there was just
one opponent left aka is the Philippines
best Tekken player and in another
youniverse Evo Japan would have been his
story a story of how he beat some of
Tekken's of best to get a win for one of
the game's most underrated regions but
that day that match was all Arslan ass
oh the packs where are the masked man
man on fire three rounds drape who can
stop them take these in trouble I'm
calling it right now dude is this poor
out straight though things are working
out there the walls level is up you
can't Hawking this man the place to pick
Oh second in Duncan you got something
scary to do man there's a mix-up there
but eight kids it's totally I leave you
got around to the board there's a punish
here all right into it is that quick
tu-204 art than here what a superstar
this weekend has been so dominant for
arson - now Ford wasn't down port is
inside it's all a cage doing right now
but all we can't win yeah that's the
thing that's very quickly attacked so
good in a follow-up call - oh he uses
resources there but she need no you
can't and you cannot win forgets arson
Ange
Oh God grateful break a now look at the
plots no you all gotta be careful
three two zero oh my goodness
Pakistan with the 308 on the Philippines
you reset the grand final
he's the witness round one rate driver
one treat oh yeah but that's gonna be
it's gonna be able to flip intro okay
with the lead right now
Carson ash though he's might be changing
it up careful tiger gotta be do that was
gonna lag it's the follow this girl is
so fair you can't really keep track of
what's coming at you a lot of time oh
man everything is like arson was going
crazy make you thought it was ready but
man no or didn't oh my gosh down to our
pitiful hold on me he'll bother that's
so damn tight he needed that one he ties
it up oh boy the static air another low
is there gonna be enough what's he gonna
do this is a lot of juicier hi times on
you gotta do this line you go oh my god
oh yeah yeah he had no choice it now
ours and running away with the
tournament oh my god that was good what
a win footage and he gets the wall here
what makes up can do it right here
and that will be another three around a
farthing oh my gosh she said the
character select screen oh he's not he
is he's gotta win two games in a row
yes what character can do that for he's
even thinking about move that cursor up
think about it moving up he might go too
low or not feel like law might have gone
pick your character works rheticus yeah
my gosh look at the side step nowadays
arson - moving forward two rounds away
from winning the tournament are the Nash
with the healthy Bob the blind he's
starting to go with a solid line but he
believed it he's like you don't even
know how to punch with this character
right now I ain't gonna let you warm up
guys the ground in the follow-up oh my
god Phoenix Japan champion it was a
clobbering 3-1 in the first set three Oh
in the second Arslan dummy take a to
lift that trophy and finally earn the
respect he deserved I am feeling like
the dope of the other but Arslan wasn't
the only person who won some respect
from the global Tekken community that
day Arsenal's win put Pakistani Tekken
on the map after taking his second
straight loss to arson knee tweeted that
he wanted to go to Pakistan to train
with a Tekken theme there you know
someone replied to me are you serious
and then Chanel replied saying does it
look like he's joking and I spoke to him
and he was actually saying to me yo swag
I want to go focus on where should I go
where all the players which which city
and a few months later the Japanese
scene arranged a series of first two
tens against their best to see how
Arsenal stacked up against them or
wouldn't beat every single Japanese
player he faced at me only taking two
relatively close losses to me who flew
over from Korea the moment he heard
arson was coming to Japan miedo planned
to come by familiar that I am from me so
he booked my flight just to beat me just
not I think he's very nice legs
he just want to learn it is fun to learn
Pakistani styles want to become more
strong Arslan has showed the world that
not only is Pakistan a region worth
taking seriously but the Korea and Japan
will not go unchallenged for the Tekken
front he also proved that the unique
Pakistani style of Tekken can stand on
the world stage that we don't know
everything about the game yet
people from all over the world can
provide new knowledge and push Tekken
forwards Tekken has not been this varied
and exciting in a very very very long
time who would have thought this thought
of the tournament that arsalan was gonna
be the Evo champion who would have
thought that there wouldn't be a Korean
in Grand Finals no one it was amazing
for Tekken in Pakistan like Korea they
are very suitable players and also they
are very competitive and when they heard
and when they saw that I want they are
working most all and they are becoming
more strong and they set me as a
benchmark right so now if they're
working hard they're becoming strong and
it is ultimately beneficial for the
whole Pakistan OGC community of stake my
second is one of the most diverse sees
in the FTC and Arslan Ash's win is a
shining example of why that kind of
diversity is an incredible thing
arsalan ash came out of nowhere to win
evo japan but his underdog story doesn't
start in the grand final it doesn't
start with his incredible loser's
bracket run through some of the best
Tekken players in the world it didn't
start with him arriving at Evo just
minutes before Poole started after being
bounced from airport to airport for days
it started in an arcade in Pakistan a
country that has never produced
world-class fighting game talent a
country that are Celyn - just put on the
map this weekend
attacking star was born and his name is
Arslan ash everyone back home new event
know about but now the whole world knows
about him thanks for watching if you
want more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you will
find anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages